the worst part that I found was actually
telling people
seeing how plants grow each spring marks
another year that Eileen rapley has
survived lung cancer
when she was diagnosed in 2016 she knew
the odds were against her so she joined
clinical trials to find new treatments
news of a breakthrough that could even
lead to a cancer vaccine has amazed her
and many in the science community
it would just take away all the Dreadful
treatments that some people have to have
at the moment it would make a vast
difference certainly
thought of being able to have a vaccine
for something is just unbelievable
unbelievable really
key to the discovery of viruses for
millions of years ago remnants of them
now form almost 10 percent of human DNA
and they're usually dormant but
scientists have discovered that B cells
from the immune system are recognizing
and targeting them when cancer develops
we went in and looked at the Cancers and
realized that actually what the
antibodies were recognizing what that B
cell response was against were fragments
of ancient viruses that had been left in
the human genome in the DNA from
infections that our ancestors had had
hundreds of thousands or millions of
years ago and that these Were Somehow
being reactivated in the Cancers and
that the immune system was recognizing
those as viral infections and creating
an antibody response against the cancers
experts say the implications for cancer
treatment including a vaccine a huge any
kind of vaccine for cancer wouldn't be
to protect you from Ever Getting cancer
it would be a way of teaching your
immune system to recognize cancer and go
after it and this kind of research could
absolutely unlock something like that in
the future a part of the puzzle which
would allow us to take our own immune
system and make it Target cancer and
that would be pretty extraordinary it's
still a long way off with much more work
need did but it's hoped it could one day
vastly improve the chances of surviving
cancer the studies behind this discovery
were based around lung cancer because it
has such high death rates but scientists
believe new treatments developed as a
result of it could be effective against
many different types of cancer while the
research is still at a very early stage
experts say the rapid development of
covert vaccines has helped to speed up
science so they're hopeful cancer
patients could be benefiting within five
to ten years Becky Johnson Sky News